[Music]
[Applause]
tom silverstein covers the packers and
he's been a busy man here but he's
taking time out
for us he covers the packers for the
milwaukee journal sentinel
let me start with the tebow story let me
give you something different here tom
what do you think about tim tebow's
chances of making the jags
uh let's see i would say
they're probably akin to
uh rogers playing for the bears maybe oh
okay that would probably be my equation
there
all right a quiet week after a wild week
so where do you
is it a good thing if you're a packers
fan that it's been quiet
it's probably a good thing yes i
you know so many things were fired right
on draft day and then of course you had
all the
reverberations after that and
little nuggets coming out and now i
think it's just
down to time i think time is
the one element that could
uh make this thing go away
it's possible i i still don't believe
that
it's gonna end well but you know
with time you start to people start to
think differently
and and view things differently and
suddenly you get closer to
actual season starting and training camp
and
and then maybe things flip a little bit
so that
that's really what it's going to come
down to in my opinion okay
why don't you think it'll work out for
uh rogers and the packers
well one i just think that with aaron
rodgers when
there's an issue and he holds a grudge
it's it's a grudge forever it's it's not
something that he gets over very easily
this could be a little bit different in
that maybe he just wanted to make his
point
and that there's some things that they
could do i'm starting to
you're starting to see um signs that
maybe he does want to come back i mean
you're seeing his surrogates
start to
say well you know it's not as bad as you
think it is
and you know everything you hear from
either
sources or people who've played with him
or
anything like that it's in my opinion
it's coming from him so maybe there is
a chance for reconciliation
yeah i'm just trying to sort through
fact and fiction here tom and i know
that you have to do this too because
there's so much that's been reported i
don't
like there nobody says yeah that's
absolutely true no that's absolutely
false because aaron hasn't said anything
and it's i mean it's tough to navigate
this
but i'm curious of the the national view
as opposed to the local view of this
are they different
yeah i mean i think from a local
standpoint now if we're talking about
the view of what this
whole thing is about yes i think
it's different if we're talking about
the viewpoint
of how this will end up i'm not sure
that um
you know the local people here also feel
like
this is not going to end well and that
he's going to probably wind up somewhere
else
but i mean from the standpoint of what
this is all about
you know we deal with aaron on a
regular basis and know a lot about them
and also know a lot about the packers
and
brian goodikinst and what they've done
to you know build around rogers and
you know there's a sentiment all through
the national media that
he's not had anybody to play with
through his
most of his career and some of us
locally
know about greg jennings and jordy
nelson and your michael finley and
randall cobb and davonte adams
and i and for getting a bunch of people
in a really good offensive line
so i i think there is some difference
yeah
and then you start to look at uh
possible destinations here for aaron
rodgers
why is denver standing out over
everybody else at least they
that that feels like denver is the front
runner if he doesn't stay in green bay
yeah it it does to me too um
i don't know why i i guess maybe for one
it's got to be in the afc
you know just history tells us it's got
to be in the afc
ted ted thompson dealt brett favre to
the jets and brian guticurus is a
ted thompson disciple he's not going to
trade him
you know to just anyone in the nfc i
don't think that could beat him
so that that's number one then you look
at
denver uh i just think that
and and i'm speculating some here but a
john elway
has got to know what an mvp quarterback
can do for him they did it with
peyton manning and elway won two super
bowls at the end of his career
and so why couldn't rogers win two for
denver
that's kind of my my sentiment or my
thought
on why it would be denver now it could
be the raiders
uh i think that probably would be
very logical i i'm not sure that um
aaron rodgers would know what he's
getting into if he goes to play for john
gruden but
you know denver denver just seems more
logical to me
uh if you could get real answers honest
answers from rogers or somebody within
the packers organization who would you
want to talk to today
rogers okay no question i mean
let's hear it you know right right from
him i i want to hear
what his gripes are what is real and
what isn't real
and is he really
dug in i mean that's that's the sense i
get that he is so dug in that he's never
going to play for the packers again
but then you always get the mixed
messages from his former teammates who
are now sort of
moving the the dial a little bit towards
he'll come back i know you know certain
things are
changed i don't know if it's going to
require brian guticans to take out a
billboard in
green bay that he's sorry he drafted me
for you to fly fly a blimp over lambo
you know i'm sorry aaron
i don't know i really don't know yeah
you're just
trying to figure out what the time frame
is on all of this and
and so jordan love is not going to be
ready again this year is that
is that right that's my
gut feeling you know when it was kind of
um tough last year because train camp
was shortened we only got to see jordan
lava
a little and then by we i mean the media
and then during once practice started
for the season you almost never see him
you just saw him
throwing drills um on air so
you couldn't really tell where he was at
the coaches give you
the usual that he's advancing but you
know
brian glitterkings made it pretty clear
when he drafted him that this was a two
or three year project
and that's kind of where i don't
understand from roger's standpoint
why there's he feels threatened about it
because
he he should be able to beat this guy
out this year
and next year and maybe even the year
after that
and i think he could fulfill his
contract easily
but you know if he plays like
if he plays like he did last year this
year
how do they cut up i mean how do you cut
a guy what if he wins the super bowl how
do you cut a
super bowl quarterback and move on to
the next guy
i just i i don't that's the part the
insecurity part that i don't understand
tom thank you for joining us i know
you've been busy covering this we
appreciate your time
anytime dan that's uh silverstein the
packers beat reporter milwaukee journal
sentinel